All right, back from Justice League. I'm just gonna come right out the gate here, and maybe start with...
The bottom line:
I did not hate it
It's not good. It's not good.
It's not good
But I didn't hate it
I feel like that's a good starting point.
I'm expecting that audiences are actually going to be very soft on the movie that they're gonna
Be willing to forgive it a lot specifically because the
the final 20 minutes of the movie are actually pretty entertaining
Um..
Otherwise..
Otherwise.. it's a mess
And it does not start out
on its best best foot. The first shot of the movie you may have heard---okay, you may have heard
that during reshoots, Henry Cavill had
facial hair.
He had had a mustache
that he grew for another movie, for another role that he was in and he was contractually prevented
from shaving it and Warner Brothers was not able to negotiate between all of the producers,
between all of the different producers, and so they did the reshoots with the mustache and
removed it digitally in post.
Aaaaaand boy does it show...
And the first shot of the movie, which is simulated iPhone footage,
Um
Is one of these shots and it is...
Not. Good.
So, this actually kind of helps me on on my end
Because it's so obvious, the parts where     [uncomfortable laughter]
The parts where they have removed the moustache
are so obvious that it becomes a really easy marker of, like, okay, "What did they go in and do reshoots of
when Whedon was brought on board?"
Aaaand, it's a lot.
Now, the final edit of a movie is always going to bias towards the reshoots
for kind of obvious reasons that it's like, all right, well they went back specifically to get that footage so
that footage is more likely to end up in
The finished movie, in the in the final cut, and in this case, like you're looking---
[sigh] I would need to go through and like actually count it, but it is substantial.
The finished cut is somewhere between 25%,
Maybe even as high as 50% depending on what sequences
were originally intended to be included, but
it's substantial: at least a quarter of the movie that you will see on screen is from Whedon's reshoots.
And gauging that is easy,
thanks to Henry Cavill's truly, truly uncanny likeness.
He appears in this movie almost entirely as CGI, a lot of body double replacement, obviously a lot of face replacement.
It's very unsettling and it indicates
a huge course correction in terms of where where they decided to go with the movie,
Midstream and in production
I would be fascinated to see the Zack Snyder version
Because this is definitely--this is definitely not it.
Like even if he has expressed his approval of it,
this is not his movie at---well...
..It's half his movie. The first half is definitely his movie.
The most straightforward comparison to make actually is Suicide Squad.
It has a lot of the same issues as--or no, I shouldn't say it has the same issues.
Because it's actually not, it's the opposite of that. It doesn't have the same issues, it has the same density of
problems as
Suicide Squad, but in completely different ways.
In fact, of the movies that have had just kind of like this baffling sort of editing that I've seen,
so if you're talking Suicide Squad, The Snowman, and now Justice League,
all three of them are actually very distinct in terms of like what their actual...problems are
So, where Suicide Squad they went in and they took
a three- or four-hour movie and
Didn't just try to compress it into
a digestible package, into a two-hour movie,
They also had all the competing edits
And they got really funky with trying to to spice up
The formula as they were doing it, so you end up with with really, really jarring, incomprehensible
Sort of editing in large chunks of it because they're moving so much around
Like they're actually restructuring
Much of the early plot of the film in order to try and make it work in a new stylized package
This one is a similar starting problem
in that they had a movie that was way too long,
But even after the reshoots, they still---
So, Whedon went and did the reshoots and then in August, they had a more or less three-hour cut
that they were test screening.
They were telling exhibitors basically to expect a
Three-hour movie
And then, the one that gets to theaters is
Two hours and so almost an hour, like 50-55 minutes, disappeared and it shows.
But rather than reorganizing and restructuring it, they just they sent an editor into the booth to be just absolutely ruthless
and just told them, like, "No mercy. Get it down to two hours
and you have two weeks to do it"
And whoever it was went in and was ruthless and just cut out.
They didn't get fancy, they didn't try to spice it up.
They just cut out every establishing shot, every brooding moment, every ounce of padding everything that wasn't
Vital to the plot or a joke.
And *jokes* brings me to the next
[pained] Thing to talk about which is tone.
There's a distinct tone problem in the movie
The two directors have very much left their own voice in the film.
You can distinctly tell the stuff that is Snyder's because it looks and feels like
Snyder's stuff.
It looks and feels like the previous two movies.
The Whedon stuff doesn't
And the Whedon decision-making in the cut shows.
And whether or not this is actually like *Whedon* Whedon or if this was
Corporate mandate from Warner Brothers, who knows, but they have, in the cut, decided to leave in
what feels like
every single
Barry Allen
Snide remark whether or not they should have, or whether or not it actually belonged
If you've seen the trailers, there's a joke that they put in the trailers, as they put rather prominent in the trailers,
where Barry basically pulls
Batman aside and they have
Back and forth about like,
"Oh man, like, it's great that you guys look like you're ready to go and do battle
But I've never done battle before I've just pushed people and run away."
It's like, hey you want to keep that!
It's kind of a funny line.
However, that line--that gag--is inserted, like sandwiched between moments of
Steppenwolf just executing people.
I'm not talking like you know, comic book movie executions,
I'm talking bone-cracking gurgle deaths that, even if they're happening off screen,
is somewhat more sinister
because the sounds that telegraph these off-screen deaths are...
...Gross.
Not inappropriate,
Just gross like the kind of tonal
sound and environment building that you have come to expect from these Snyder Superman movies.
And so to go from Steppenwolf basically ripping a person's head off
to Barry Allen jokin' jokin' about how he's not ready to do battle
back to Steppenwolf killing someone, like breaking their back and throwing them into a wall is
Mm. Not great flow.
Like, maybe pick one tone or the other.
The climax of the movie has a completely different tone
Than everything else and, to its benefit,
The the dialogue doesn't get Whedon-esque ever.
I mean aside from how Barry's kind of always in there, but it's not a problem.
It's not.
Overall, it's not not really there, but the
Whedon understands why people like Superman and
Whedon has--you can tell because they're reshoots because of the mustache removal--Whedon has
made Superman into kind of the Superman that everybody sort of
Wanted slash expected all along and so the the climax is a lot more lighthearted,
It's a lot more adventuresome, it's a lot more friendly,
It's less oppressive a tone
People are happy?
Like, they're making jokes because they're having fun not because it's gallows humor
It's very weird like
[laughs]
Even the parts that aren't Super Obvious Mustache Removal, it's still very kind of uncanny watching
Henry Cavill's Superman
smile.
It's its own kind of unsettling because it's like they've given him just this resting sneer
for two movies now and
I've spent so much time with that sneer that
watching him smile is a little
It's a little unsettling and a weird kind of thing that they did with this movie is their sort of whole approach to
Dealing with Batman vs. Superman is just to ignore the parts of the
Everything about Batman vs Superman that they just don't want to deal with.
Which would not normally be a problem except for how
Intrinsically tied to Batman vs. Superman it is.
Like, literally everything about the plot. This movie does not make a lick of sense if you haven't seen
Batman vs. Superman, it is a hard sequel.
So, in that regard it's very weird to have everyone kind of behaving as
Though events in Batman vs. Superman went differently.
One of the main things is that the whole first act, like prologue into the first act of this movie,
is predicated on the explicit
Declaration that since Superman's death things have gotten worse, but
There is tied to that--and this comes in heavily during the the intro credits sequence, which is a
very Zack Snyder introduction.
Like, you will have Watchmen flashbacks if if you watch it.
The storytelling in that sequence implies that
all of these things, from war and poverty and whatnot, are escalating dramatically
as a direct consequence of the death of Superman. That's what it says
using cinematic language.
...And also regular language
Because people, in slightly different words, say exactly that.
The problem there is that the world-building assumption of Batman vs Superman
completely disagrees with that assessment because the world-building assumption of Batman vs Superman is that the world was
a crap hole
And Superman could do nothing to stem the tide of it. That is core to the identity of
Batman vs. Superman is
Revolving around this whole
hand wringing over Superman
Actually making the world worse by
Doing stuff like that, that he wasn't making the world better and the things that he was doing weren't
Fixing anything substantial and he
wasn't giving people hope, not en masse.
They kept saying, "Oh, well, he's inspiring people," but by and large the world
in its entirety, in the sense of The World was you know cynical and decaying and unworthy of Superman.
Perry White has a whole diatribe in
In Batman vs. Superman about how the world, how America's conscience died with
Jack Robert and and Martin.
You know that I...
[prolonged cringe]
...I just had somebody in my mentions a couple days ago
Arguing that the the central premise of Batman vs. Superman is that
The world was too cynical for him, the world didn't deserve Superman.
And I mean that doesn't work in the face of the fact that, you know..
Superman in that movie is an asshole
Anyway, they do a very thorough job of establishing in
BVS that the world sucks and things are bad, and
No matter what Batman, no matter what Superman does, nothing seems to actually get better.
So to go from that to,
"Oh, man, things are, you know,
Basically things were roses back when Superman was alive, but now everything's fallen part,"
is kind of weird and more than a little strange.
I suppose maybe you could view it as a bit of a spoiler-ish that Superman's in this a lot, but it's hard to avoid
because he's actually in this movie a lot.
The trailer kind of waffled back and forth between pretending that he was going to stay dead and
just acknowledging that like
Yeah, he's back
'Cuz he comes back, actually they they resurrect him about
Halfway through the movie (?) in a sequence
That is completely devoid of tension
Because they need to move the plot along.
Okay, the middle segment of this movie is actually where the editing is is worst.
So the League
gets together and
They have a showdown with Steppenwolf.
Let's do a little bit of a plot rundown...
...Steppenwolf wants three MacGuffins. He takes one from the Amazons,
He takes one from the Atlanteans, and then he's looking for the third, and
The League has a short little showdown with him
And they managed to kinda get him to scram. He takes off
and they go and grab the third MacGuffin and hold on to it and decide to use it to resurrect Superman and
the time between deciding
To resurrect him or to use the MacGuffin to to cure death, and
Superman being just live again is about five minutes. Maybe ten.
It goes very quickly with zero complications more or less
And is a very silly sequence, but not in an intended silly way.
It's just silly because it moves way too fast and then
The big, the patchiest moment ends up happening in this where
Superman comes back alive and MacGuffin goes flying into the air, and then they show it landing on top of a cop car.
It's a mother box by the way.
They show the mother box landing on top of a cop car and then everybody ignores it
Despite the fact they know, the team knows explicitly
That if Steppenwolf gets his hands on this third mother box, he will be able to destroy the world.
And they know he has two.
They know he has two, they've got the third, and they cannot let him get it.
It lands on this cop car and they just leave it there.
They just ignore him.
There's Flash, Wonder Woman, Cyborg, Aquaman, Batman.
Five.
They got five of them, five people and all five people
go and just
Have this confrontation with Superman.
Okay, fine with this so far.
Then, in a hilarious moment, they see Steppenwolf's, like, Stargate pillar thing open his portal--
[Portal opening sounds]
--Opens.
They cut away to the mother box lying on top of this cop car
then back to the heroes and the heroes are like, "Oh, crap!
The mother box! We gotta go get it"
And then the portal just closes and it's like, "Oh, I guess Steppenwolf has it now
We screwed up
Dang"
It's
It's pretty funny. You don't even see
You don't even see Steppenwolf in that segment, so that is probably the cludgiest editing moment where, like, I don't know
what originally happened there.
Everything in, not quite everything, a huge, huge portion
Of that sequence is clearly reshoots, so potentially all of it is reshoots.
So who knows what that's papering over.
You know who knows what was originally supposed to happen in that chunk of the movie to get from here to there
And the Superman reshoots are so pervasive,
There are so many of them, that they're obvious, that I'm actually
Kind of wondering
If they
If Superman were ever really in the movie
sort of
The reason I say that---
Like, clearly, he was gonna always come back, but when and how seems to have been completely redone
during the Whedon stuff because
Huge chunks of the climax are clearly Whedon.
The resurrection of Superman sequence is clearly Whedon.
It's
It's so substantive in terms of the importance within the structure of the movie
that it doesn't just feel like, "Oh, we needed to kind of
Fix some shots, we needed to smooth over some dialogue,
We needed to maybe, you know, punch it up a bit."
It feels, it goes to the level of
This was probably completely different at one point.
Also
During the sequence where they do the resurrection, the mother box looks completely different
Than it does at every other time in the movie, so there's a not...
Unlikely...
There's a not unlikely chance that
Resurrecting Superman may have once been much much much later in the film
And did not require the motherbox at all and that that was
Reworked and
That there was originally a completely different way that Steppenwolf got ahold of the third one.
I don't know.
It's really confusing and
The middle chunk of this movie is what I think a lot of people are going to end up sort of
Fixating on because it's, it's a mess
But then yeah, they finally
They go and---
Actually, no, before that there's a really funny kind of side conversation
So during the, like, five minutes that they're debating whether or not they should resurrect Superman,
one of the complaints that's brought up or one of the
philosophical questions that is posed  is you lose something in dying and,
You know, your dying
Changes your personality and in this case,
it absolutely,
100% does because it turns out that dying made Superman into less of a prick!
He smiles now, he jokes,
He has a sense of humor. He looks like someone who knows what fun is.
He's played completely different, Completely Different, in
in his post-death stuff at least after he kind of snaps back to.
Accepting that he's back alive, which which goes pretty quickly.
It goes by fast enough that
characters actually comment on how quickly he came to terms with, you know, not being dead anymore.
So yeah, then the last 20 minutes are
A big long action sequence.
A lot of it sucks and is very boring action sequence,
But the actual fight against Steppenwolf, particularly once Superman shows up, it's actually got some
It's got some character to it, it's fun, it's dynamic.
There's actually stuff that
happens
It gets very
Comic book-y in a good way
finally
and leaves you kind of wishing that, like, "Oh,
If only we had had this Superman for two movies already
instead of a quarter of a movie."
Yeah, and um...
I'm trying to think of other major things that really stood out to me
There's a lot of teleporting in the movie. I mean this isn't a huge problem per se like it's
I don't know. It's it's one of those
Its one of those sticking points where it's like they get a little too
loose with the time frame at times, particularly character movement.
Like, people will just
pop back and forth from
from metropolis to Kansas and back, like,
instantaneously in a very weird way
and now, when it's the superheroes doing it, you're, like, whatever
they're superheroes, but there's a point where ma Kent does it as well, like, she's explicitly in Metropolis and then
right away
She's in Kansas again, and it's like okay, that's just kind of
That's just kind of sloppy
Also, there's a scene near the beginning where it's very clearly a Zack Snyder scene
where Lois
Has to talk for an extended period of time and it leaves you painfully aware that
Zack Snyder has never once bothered to sit down and actually develop this character and her voice, and
It's awful. It's.. it is.. it is..
truly, truly abysmal dialogue
And yeah.
Yeah
Sooo a weird mix of
fun Silver Age superhero action and...
Modern Snyder...
Grimness
But like I said back at the beginning, I think audiences are gonna give it a lot of leeway just because
the ending is is pretty fun and
Personally, I-- I don't, I don't hate it
I enjoyed parts of it. It didn't leave a sour taste in my mouth because it's not a misanthropic cesspit
So just the simple fact that it seems to have found a modicum of joy
Makes it a lot more bearable despite its numerous, numerous flaws
And yeah
So...
Probably don't go see it because it's still bad, but if you do go see it, you won't
it shouldn't leave you in pain and
hating the world
So there's that.